Hello and welcome.
It's July 27, 2023, and we're
here in Acton, guest stream, number 15.1
with Valeria Beckhatini and Anna C
unica. This is going to be a very
interesting and cool presentation and
discussion on selfless minds, unlimited
bodies, homeostatic, bodily self
regulation and meditative experiences.
There will be a presentation followed by
a discussion. So thank you both for
joining and to you Valeria, for the
presentation. Thank you Diana, very
much. I'm very happy to be here with
Anna. Presenting pathavara
wider project. This is a paper about
what happened in selfless state from a
Homo Sapie bodily self regulation
perspective. So it's as I said, it's
part of a wider project that consists in
both theoretical and experimental
components.
Today we're going to look at meditation.
So for people that are not really
familiar with that, meditation is a
practice that engaged attention to self
regulate physiological and cognitive
activity. What we're interested here is
that people that meditate with a certain
experience, so for example,
meditating in the past two years with
regularly, like some hours per week,
they consistently report losing one
sense of the self or having selfless
experiences. But not only that, they
also report to have bodily alterations.
So alterations in the procession of the
body. That has been called expansion,
oceanic boundlessness, dissolution of
body boundaries. And since you are
particularly interested in this kind of
phenomenal experience, we have proposed
to frame them unlimited body,
just for clarity. So our question
here is what exactly? And the question
that will follow the whole presentation
in the background is what exactly is
lost when experienced meditators report
losing their self and the body? So let's
first look very briefly at what the
self is, or the sense of self is. So
this concept is so complex and so wide
that has been debated since the
beginning of philosophy. And of course,
it might be so intuitive that it's also
very hard to define. But one very
old and used definition is the
unitary or unique individual eye. The
first person perspective, that Latin was
called the subjectin. So something that
lay under all our stream of experience,
thoughts and whatever else happens to
us, that's the subject.
However, more recently in cognitive
science, we are appealing to a more
common definition of sense of self, a
bit more exhaustive, that is defined
as a multidimensional construct. And
here we will come back on
this concept later and we'll unpack it a
bit more. So the aim
of this presentation will be to
first of all, lay down the fact that in
self experiences, the biological
organism, so to speak, the human body
remains successfully repregulated. And
this might be very intuitive but it
needs us then to see that during
selfless experiences what we
propose is that they may be tacitly
accompanied or implicitly underlined by
enhanced connectedness with this
successful self regulation that we
propose to link it with a perceptually
attenuated body or what has been already
called transparent body.
And this allows us to propose
but it's of course on a working process
and we are very open to feedback at any
stage of this presentation that the term
selfless states may be misleading
because what is lost is an ordinary way
to mentally model the self relation to
the body and the world. So our
roadmap is composed as follows
first I will passing through
debates and definitions of losing
oneself and body. So that means I will
go through alterations in these three
dimension during massive state
and then I will introduce Keen concept
of predictive process in the active
infrastructure framework that are useful
in our explanation. So that
then I can unpack
the role of the biological self
organization and homostatic self
regulation in constituting our sense of
self. And then pass to our more
claim that the processes like
somatosensory, attenuation and
transparent self modeling are a key
mechanism underlying the phenomenology
of deep mathematical states. And this
then will allow us to draw our
conclusions and present ongoing related
projects.
So let's come back to the sense of self.
So when
one has to investigate the sense of
self, of course, as I said it's so wide
concept that so many definitions and
characterization of the sense of self
has come up in philosophy and cognitive
science. So we have terms like minimal
self experience, selfhood sense of
ownership and all of this. And for other
part I think we have just to stick to a
common definition that comes for example
from a similar paper from Gallagher 2000
that defines as a multidimensional
construct composed by minimal or
embodied components and narrative or
reflective components. So to unpack a
little bit these two concepts the
minimal or embodied experience of the
sense of self is the basic implicit
functioning of the body of
the ongoing moment. So the stream of
experience that happens to me right now
can be defined as my minimal sense of
self. So I don't really need to
have an explicit knowledge about myself
to have this kind of dimension.
And these can be further unpacked
through the concept of prereflective
self consciousness that comes from a
phenomenological tradition. Tracing back
from peak
argue that parts of our self conscious
does not need any reflection to happen
there or explicit thought. It happens
in a way tambourian is consistently
before reflection. And then on top of
this we build our narrative or our
reflections about ourself. And this is
more linked to self identification
processes or self monitoring, self
recognition and introspection.
Introspection, it's the ability
of introspection. So perceive
yourself or reflect about yourself in an
explicit way. So you do need to have
that biography or an explicit memory
about yourself in order to tackle this
aspect of the sense of self.
So in deep meditative states there
is alterations in the sense of self and
it's up to debate which dimension are
affected by that. And it's
far from clear what actually happens
to this kind of dimension and more and
many more other dimensional sense of
self. And we are here to unpack a
little bit this. We proposed these
quotations from Fashion 2008 where
it suggested that enduring deep massive
states one experiences oneself as these
very moments of consciousness. This is
quotation that may reveal some position
about the debate what happens to
the sense of self. So in this case it's
argued that meditation reveal a very
moment of consciousness. So there is
something that is true consciousness or
something that is the real
consciousness. And this actually has
broke through the concept of pure
consciousness. So something that stayed
there and it's
purified by everything, by also the
body. And there is so many definition of
this pure consciousness. We brought some
example like ownerless consciousness,
the consciousness that doesn't have an
owner, that doesn't have a self. So it
doesn't have a proper sense of self that
walked or that owns this consciousness.
Mastinger has worked on the minimal
phenomenal experience defining aspecial
a temporal dimensional consciousness.
And this is very supportive because it's
consistent with the Buddhist
philosophical stance of no self. So for
most tradition of Buddhism, there is
no self. The self, it's an illusion.
And it comes to our psychology when we
enter in contact with the world and with
the sensations of the world and certain
patterns of behavior that elicit the
sense that we have a self. So, as I
said, meditation allows us to
access this pure consciousness for
supporters of this thesis and rebuilds
one choose an essential nature of
subjective and we bring this into
debate. There are also
people that argue against this and it
has been called by Matthew in their
special issues, the Ubitiquity thesis.
So the UBIT thesis claim that essential
self is ubiquitous to all states of
consciousness and sometimes it appeals
to the immunity to error through
misidentification argument of self
ascription reports, which is simpler
than this long name. And it's basically
the fact that I can say that I had
a wonderful experience and
this wonderful experience may be true or
false on this weekend.
I can do mistakes, I can make mistakes,
but I cannot not say that I didn't
have these wonderful experiences because
the moment in which I report I
have a perspective on this. So I cannot
really be mistaking on the fact that I'm
reporting this. Maybe I was dreaming,
maybe it wasn't a wonderful experience,
but it's me that I'm reporting. So the
moment I'm reporting this, it means that
I have to be there. And this applies
also to when I ascribe myself selfless
state, I had a selfless state. This is
very controversial. Other problems on
top of that are cross cultural problems
also addressed in the literature. So
this experience selfless states may be
influenced by certain vows
or certain beliefs that meditator
endorse, especially during
especially expert meditators. And the
other thing is these
all cross
cultural analysis and debate about the
self may be also partially due to a
verbal misunderstanding. So that the
western philosophy may have problems
about the self that actually the Eastern
probably philosophy is not really
addressing. So there might be some
incommensurability of problems there.
But as also we said in the paper, it's
not that we want to address the Buddhist
philosophical problems, rather we want
to bring insight from these to our
problems. So,
given this debate, we want to propose a
shift in the focus. So we don't want to
start by looking at consciousness and
trying to solve things about the self,
but we want to start by focusing on the
body. So we proposed a shift in focus in
the bodily experience, examining this
deep mercy state.
So let's start by the subjective
experience of the body or the study of
the subjective experience of the body,
which is phenomenology. In the
tradition, our body has a unique status.
So the anatomical structure of the body
has been called by USA Kobe. So the
living body, the body that I can observe
and others can be observed. So it's the
object among the other object, they
would say. But it's not only that
because it's an object that I can live
from inside. So it has been called the
light, the lived body or the body as I
leave it from inside, as I said.
So what happens to these kind of
dimension? Again, we can unpack this and
see how the meditative states affect
them. So from the point of view of the
life believed body,
we already know, and I will unpack a
little bit more. So we have already said
that we have called unlinuated body
experiences the reports that spoke about
this fading of the body boundaries.
So the body boundary has been defined as
a cognitive emotional perception of
one's body surface. That's just a
definition. We can also debate about
this. But what it's important about for
us that our sense of body boundaries is
flexible and dynamic. It's not fixed
because we are in the realm of the body
as felt from inside. There is an
interesting study that exemplified this
concept in relation to meditation by
Jumpren in 2016, though it has worked
late further on on this as well.
But I find it interesting to look at
this image because this is part of a
self report measurement that they used
on a sample of people that had been
trained in meditation, in particular
with body scanning. So that people had
to systematically scan sensation running
the body. And the result is that in less
than four months of practice, so not
actually not the expert, they really
started to report an increased tendency
to go towards the almost
imperceptible perception of the body.
So they conclude that meditation
can be actually studied in this sense
where it affects our sense of body
boundaries. And they saw significant
results also in relation to increased
mood, happiness and decreased
anxiety and rumination. But this is just
another story that will come back later.
So I find interesting also this
quotation by Fink here in this paper
it's talking about why ego dissolution
may be better understood as ego
expansion. And then ego
dissolution comes in a later
interpretation. And so
I will read it. It's not the feeling of
self that dissolves, but the boundary
between a feeling of self and the
feeling of anything else in
consciousness. So here again Pink is
talking about consciousness but from our
perspective this quotation is pretty
informing because it goes in our
direction as well because he says
it's not that you're losing really
yourself. This experience is dependent
on how you actually perceive your
boundary with you and what you don't
consider you. So self fading of the self
other distinction ability.
So here it comes predictive
processing acting framework because we
want to basically
breach this phenomenal subjective
experience to cognitive phenomena and
underlying mechanistic explanation.
Indeed, predictive processing activities
have recently used for this purpose.
Also meditation research and
psychopathology research and so on. So
in this presentation I will use them in
an interchangeable way but following
certain trends. But it doesn't
have to be, it's also under debate and
I will also give API purely
I don't know how to say theoretical
perspective on that I will not go too
much technical. So briefly,
this framework considers brains
as predictive machine or as Friesen
likes to say, consider brain
as a fantastic organ which is
because it's not only able to do amazing
things, but also because it really
generates fantasies about the world.
And this is because in order to act,
interact with itself and the world
around, the brain constantly anticipate
the current state of affairs in
order to make sense of the sensorium or
the stream of experiences that happens.
So it possess or embody or utilizes,
it depends on the commitment a
generative model which is a model that
keep tracks of regularity of the world
and forms predictions out of it in a
hierarchical way. So highly rated
prediction goes down to match
sensory data and sensory
data goes up to map
to affect the predictions, to update
the model. However, every prediction
comes with a degree of error
which sometimes is called prediction
errors. So the prediction error
is a discrepancy between prediction and
sensory input so that a new model is
generated and they say the first
imperative or the only imperative of the
system is actually minimizing the
prediction errors so that the model can
most efficiently cope and interact and
act in the world. However, it's not
the only imperative because as I will
introduce in this slide,
the system has also to estimate
the confidence or likelihood or
precision of prediction in order to
evaluate the prediction errors that are
coming from the discrepancy.
So that the generative model has to
compute in a fine way how
much precision to assign to the
prediction or prediction errors and
I choose this image because it renders
well how the distribution
are set depending
on the precision citation. So if you
have a precise prediction error then
the posterior distribution will be
closer to the prediction error. Well,
the imprecise prediction error have
little effect on the prior, so does the
posture distribution will be closer to
the prior and this is very important
because if the precision
estimator are not weighted correctly
then the system generates false
inference that will not able to the
system to interact efficiently and
update the model efficiently.
So, so far we have mostly
talked about prediction error
minimization by updating the
model. However, the system can also
active sample the world active modify
the prediction error or the world in
order to fit the prediction
errors to the world. And this comes into
play active inference that builds upon
the free energy principle where it's
based on the idea that living organisms
maintain themselves with an optimal set
of states that comes from the second low
thermodynamics of schrodinger.
So given that it
comes into play how attention
is analyzed or examined under
this framework. So given that that the
organism has to maintain within these
optimal assessor states by maintaining
an optimal balance between computation
and precision optimization so wasting
between prediction and prediction
errors, attention comes into place as a
modulation of this precision of sensory
data working as a search light. So in
other words, it optimizes signal to
noise ratio. It's one of the way that we
have to put
in place this local optimization of
precision estimates and this is very
important why we bring into attention
because meditation has a systematic
and use of attention
resources and we will come
back into that a bit further on in this
presentation. And given that
we are interested in okay,
we have seen the lived body, what
happens to the phenomenal experience now
we're interested in what happens to the
corporate, what happens to believing
body that can be observed by the
organism during medicine states.
In this we bring into play other two
important concepts in active inference
which is way to self regulate that
underlie all embassy experience, so all
subjective experience, so two ways or
one way that then is also active. So the
first way is homeostasis which is
the maintenance of required optimal
state by survival and reproduction of
self organizing biological systems. So
for example, I cold and I use my
internal resources to keep my
states into optimal state so I
start shivering. However, I can also put
in place active modification in the
world so that I'm not cold anymore.
So for example, I take a blank, this is
called allostasis. So it's active
engagements and modification about the
environment in order to maintain myself
in optimal state for survival.
So we can say of course,
human bodies are self organizing
biological system aiming at keeping
these internal states within a certain
viable range for survival. Now,
given that we will come back again to
the phenomenology of touch.
I'm going to do this for the second time
to then wrap up everything again.
So, we have talked about fermology of
the body. However,
we haven't underlined the importance
that the touch and proximal sound has
for our lip.
Our as Nikka and colleagues has already
proposed, our proximal sense are central
for our minimal sense of self.
And on top of that, we bring
into play the fact that different kinds
of touch can convey different experience
of the sense of self or sense of
boundaries. So for example, imagine
yourself that you are in a city
of Portugal or California,
you touching the whole environment with
your body. You may feel that you have a
sense of immersiveness or that your body
boundaries are slowly a bit becoming
less clear. And this experience, it's
actually a bit similar to the
experiences of sensory deprivation
states where people are put in a salty
water and they let them flow for some
moments. Sensory deprivation states are
not really all deprived because you have
other activities in the body and
movements that produce signals that you
are actually aware of. However, in both
these experiences, the body boundary
seems to fade a little bit. However, if
you're in the sea and you're swimming
and then you touch the rock with your
hand, you clearly will feel yourself as
separated as something different from
what you're actually touching, right?
Sense of separation.
This phenomenology can be brought into
active inference through the mechanism
of some of the sensory attenuation which
comes from the sensory tinuation.
So this process happens when the
systemicates its own action.
So for example, I take a glass and
in this moment my rena has already
created afferent copies of this action
and the sensory consequences of this.
So whenever I grab this
glass, the sensory constant that happens
to my body are slightly
attenuated. And this is why we cannot
tickle ourselves because the prediction
errors comes at. Not surprising this
has implication for our
embodied experience in the world.
Because we feel that we are in immediate
contact with ourselves in the world.
And this is because our conscious
experience are mediated by transparent
or non perceived cognitive processes.
So that the system can leave behind or
disatten self related sensory
processing. And these allow to allocate
resources to perception and action
involved in the processing of the object
of interest. So for example, when LeMans
confiscated this example of the cherry,
when I have to take object salient
for me, I'll be much more interested in
picking the object and I will not really
focus on my arm moving in
picking that. So that the system needs
to compute and maintain a fine balance
between external and internal components
of somatosensory attenuation. And this
is very important for a sense of self as
well. So we
need to understand and it's not that we
need, but in order for us to have a
sense of self. We normally have a sense
of what we are and what we are not.
But for the brain as
agents end up with the brain, we compute
this distinction. So where the self ends
and where do work begins or do I move my
arm or my arm is moved by something or
someone? So central attenuation
plays a role in these distinctions
in building multisensory bodily self
representations. So that the sense of
the self embody is subject to the and
phenomenally transferred. That means
that when we act in the world and we
interact, we normally disattend the
way we are in the world. Because we need
to be in contact, in direct contact with
the world. If we always attend it to our
body and ourself in
the sense that we will be hyper
reflexive then we will be actually will
be impaired in what we normally do.
And this is actually a condition that we
will talk about later.
So that in active images the sense of
self is an ongoing inferential process
centering the body. So what we propose
is what is lost during
selfless experience is an ordinary way
to mentally model self in relation to
the body and the world. So that if we
think about the self as I propose here
the iceberg where the narrative self is
what we see but the renewal self is what
we actually are composed of and it's
actually larger but we are not aware of.
Similarly, when we have self experience
we may have also this inferential
process where we think we have lost
ourselves.
However,
we have gathered some evidence in the
fact that meditation facilitate
autonomic regulation involved in
homostatic processes. That means for
example that meditation increase the
synchronization of cardiac and
respiratory system. This is connected
with reduced levels of blood glucose
or blood pressure and heart rate
variability. So there is a success.
Medication helps to successfully self
regulate the body especially in
comparison to stress that actually does
the opposite.
And on top of that, meditation help us
to attune us to our physiological
interceptive awareness. And it
does it so they say, by enhancing the
processing of extraceptive interceptive
stimuli which doesn't have to be
understanded as a maladaptive
increased body awareness, but rather an
adaptive body awareness which is a
distinction that we can come back later
if people are interested or they ask
about.
These evidence are also in line with
evidence of meditation that promotes
self regulation of pain and pain and
pleasantness. So three day attentional
training, the meditation allow
you're actually able to self regulate
the pain and not really like the
sensation of the pain because actually
it gets very fewer but the automatic
behavioral patterns that comes in
association with the pain. So there is
a lot of also self regulation on
emotions and so on.
So the body does not literally disappear
actually it stays at the very center as
I propose here at the center as we
propose it in the paper and I propose it
through this image at the center of a
cycling. So self
regulatory processes allow the
subjective experience to lose oneself so
that the sense of the body remains
present in the background. And this for
example, it's very clear from this
report from a person undergoing
this kind of experience that they say
that there remains a sense that there is
a body without any experience of a sense
of boundary.
So this is not
very last slide but we come to our wrap
up of our claim attenuating the
self and limiting the body which is also
the title of our paper. So,
starting from the fact that all medicine
practices across the tradition require
systematic and carefully fully crafted
body preparation to enter this deep
method selfless state. So it doesn't
happen that all of a sudden you just
have a selfless state which actually may
happen more similarly with psychedelic.
But with meditation you
need to pass through gradually a many
different state or many different level
of concentration.
That happens when you have around
a predictable environment
and you do so by building prior
expectation. So you have to keep your
body in a certain position of posture.
As you say in this image, the person is
seated with a very straight,
not very, but a straight back relaxed.
This is very important meditation,
banded legs and so on. And then you need
at least in the most
part of your practice, you need safe
predictable environments with
temperature that enables you to maintain
your homostatic processes.
So all these conditions are necessary
for your successful homostatic self
regulation. In this sense when
parts of preparation to enter
then after the state of confrontation,
the meditator can let go and leave
behind self related processes and
process the body transported or it can
attenuate them attenuate the body
can be attenuated. So our
claim is that a transfer essential self
and body may underline the phenomenology
of losing oneself and blurring
body boundaries as reported during
meditative states.
So our conclusion is that we have
proposed a shift in focus on homostatic
body self regulation in examining deep
meditative states. The experience of
having a body living self organism
biological system is never lost in this
process. Rather it stay transferred at
its very center, self attenuated yet
very much present and hands alive.
So that the self model is attenuated to
become transparent and hands processed
in the background. Now giving this
conclusion now I'm going to present
related project. The first one is still
on the theoretical side. So we are in
the realm of active inference model in
meditation research. There is a radio
literature about that that
have studied different kinds of
meditation techniques like focused
attention, open monitoring,
nondual awareness and
they all study from
Laconin in 2023 or Laconin and
Lactar in 2021.
They have for example showed that these
attention techniques profoundly alter
typical mental experiences and
for example focus meditation is
meditation that engage attention
on one specific object experience.
For example the breath and in active
inference term it means that precision
is estimated one sensory input which
means that it reduce the impact of the
other thoughts and parallel processes
that are going on or often
open monitoring meditation is
the engaging of attention to one's
experience as a whole. So the whole
stream of experience without selecting
anything in particular. So that in an
activatory terms it has been described
as assigning equal precision to all
these experiencing promoting non
reactive sensing. And this is connected
also why medicine are good
in self regulated regulate pain.
So we will also build our
model on self modeling based
on the previous literature which is
integration. And then
going experimental we want to bring into
the table application of what we're
researching and potential benefit may be
for cases of people or individual that
suffer from disrupted body awareness
or disrupted self awareness. And there
is a relatively recent
condition that has been studied that
is depersonalization. So depersonization
is the disruption of both body and self
awareness and it's a very heterogeneous
condition, there is a lot of different
dimensions that occurs but
generally it's connected with feelings
of heaviness disconnection feeling the
body as an object, rather they're a
transfer and medium of experience which
simply is called disembodiment.
It is linked with difficulties in
concentration and attention, often
comorbid with depression, rumination and
anxiety. And recently Chow Nuka and
colleagues has also proposed AIDS
characterized by failures in attenuating
somatosentry signals.
So based on what we have
previously said and based on
how this condition affects
large number of population, we want to
test certain hypotheses.
So the first one would be that higher
somasocentric attenuation Correlate with
more feeling of aliveness and wide
openness in experienced meditators and
rather lowest somascentric attenuation
Correlate with feelings of unrealness
thatness in people experience deeper
solidation. And on
the other hand, severe homostatic
dysregulation of bodily states during
deep meditative states may lead to
negative emotional outcomes and Abernant
self experience. This comes from to the
fact that depression and meditation
can both create stressing negative
outcomes and it's interesting to see how
this happened and what are the
commonalities and differences in that.
And also we have dealt in the realm of
spatial temporal perception which is
connected also with mood disorders or
like depression and anxiety and also
with depersonalization.
However, in depersonalization there is
no specific items in the questionnaire
that is usually used for measuring which
is the Cambridge Depressionization
scale. So we want to test this as well
and we want to test it in people
reporting selfless and disembodied
experience so both pathological and non
pathological conditions. So part
of this hypothesis we are really going
through this is our team coming from
Humboldt University where I come from as
well Simon Wendelman, but also
University College London with Ines and
Joseph first study is as I said
about. Time perspective. So we want to
analyze how
people with high traits of depression
correlate with dimension of the time
perspective so they are more future
oriented or more negative oriented. Our
hypothesis that they're more negative
past oriented so they're stuck
in a very long
present moment, but also they're
the tendency of ruminating. So always
going to past negative memories.
Since this is titled Last in Dark Times
the Effect of the Personalization
Experience in on Time Perspective And
these we are already in the analysis of
the data but it's
an ongoing steel study.
So we have preliminary data on this.
While studies too we are in the
recruitment phases but we are almost
there and encompass the high
traits of people individual into high
traits of depression and meditators.
I want to see through a set
of questionnaires and a behavioral task
how they may differ in the sense of
self, body and motion. Of course, they
are very wide and concepts so there is
always room for feedback
and replications and so on.
We have selected these tasks, the embody
tasks adopted from new menma where
individual participants has to color
parts of the body in relation to
activation that they feel by reading
certain emotional story. So these
stories are supposed to validate it to
elicit certain emotions in the body and
then people colors parts of the body.
And then we will see how people with
hydrates and the visualization may say
will differ in this. And we will also
compare with other questionnaires that
we have put this and potential
title is emotional Body Maps of Thought
Detachment, Interpersonalization and
Meditation. And with this I thank you
all and that's it. We are open
for discussion. Thank you.
Awesome. Thank you very much. Valeria,
you are muted. Donna. Thank you.
Valeria. Great. Well,
very fascinating presentation. Perhaps
Anna first and then our other colleagues
who have joined. Would be awesome to
hear your path to be
here on this work and any reflection or
questions you have on it.
Is it my turn? Sure. Did I miss? Yeah.
So obviously I don't have many questions
because it's like we wrote this
together.
But I think what I would
like just to add not really a question
is I really like to
see so
for instance like in ideal world would
be nice to get all the traditions
of the meditative experiences and how
they relate to the body and make a very
precise prediction on what exactly they
will kind of predict in terms of certain
sensory experiences and how this can be
interpreted through different
theoretical lenses. I think that could
be really interesting because I think
one of the problems, the challenges that
we have right now is that we have so
many concepts, so many approaches and
kind of, like, scattered all over the
map, and I think would be really nice to
narrow down, because, as you said,
Daniel so everybody knows
what meditation is. Everybody knows at
least one person that meditates in life
and everything, but it's really unclear
what exactly we are after and why.
In certain cases, this is kind of like
beneficial, and in other cases,
basically it has negative consequences.
And this is why precisely we are doing
this project on depersonalization and
meditation. And I can share with you
informally, Scoop, but data
is here, so we kind of like can share
with. So what we did in this project,
basically we took people with typical
controls that don't have
depersonalization and never meditated.
Right? So it's kind of like, yeah,
never did that. And then we took people
that meditated, and then we looked
at whether they have kind of like high
or low traits of depersonization. And
then we took people with depersonization
that never meditate. Right.
So we have this inclusion and exclusion
criteria and yeah, it's really
interesting to find what our findings
is. It's really difficult to find people
that have experience and
low depersonalization skills, low
depersonization traits. Right. So most
of them, they actually have high
depersonalization. But then it's
interesting to see how that contrasts
with the people that have
depersonalization and no vegetation
experience. Right. So that's something I
would like to carry on to
reach the community.
That's something we'll definitely carry
on with. Valerian the next steps and
also with some people that I have here
in the chat, julia and Simone.
So Simone will going to work with us on
also. Somatosensory attenuation through
different have some
without scooping. We have also some very
interesting results coming up. We just
finished data collection on intentional
binding and depersonization. So related
to the sense of agency.
That's all for me for now.
We're kind of like in between because
Valerie represented very well, like the
theory part and the studies are
literally just getting hot from the oven
now. And we hope that in September it's
like we're going to get them out.
Yeah, but the data is in the box, so
that's very exciting and yeah, we have
the results. Thank you,
Danielle, again for this platform. It's
really nice. And as I said, I really
hope that after this discussion, we'll
have more opportunities
to change, exchange and discuss.
We also plan to organize something
around alteration of self consciousness
across various conditions and also
decarbonization in Lisbon next year. So
maybe you can cross the pond and check
for yourself that we have a nice airport
in Lisbon. Yeah.
Cool. Well, good to get the appetizer
before the entree. So that's very
awesome about just how much theory and
even unconventional scientific theory,
like world knowledge traditions come
into play and then what it looks like to
take that experimental step to make it
scientific is definitely what I saw in
the talk. Julia or Simone, do you want
to give any reflection or any thoughts
or questions? Yes. Can you hear me?
Yes. I actually have three questions I
noted down. I think the first one
because it's just for me personally,
I'm curious about that is that those
deep meditative selfless states I think
that can also be reached while doing
yoga, right? Basically the opposite
of sitting still. It's like a sort of
repetitive movement actually. So I'm
wondering do those movements have to be
perfectly predictable in order to be
attenuated and then reaching the same
state? Or is that like a different
different concept or how do you put that
in your framework?
I think here you brought mainly two
topics. One is, is it possible to reach
deep matter states also not sitting
in a still position? And the answer is
yes.
However, there is not so much research
on that. So I can talk about anecdotal
knowledge, but I did
not read so much about walking
meditation effect, usually walking
meditation or of course you talk about
yoga. I know, but that's what I would
say, that walking meditation is used as
a complementary practice through the
sitting. So I would say it's hard
to reach deep meditative states only by
walking meditation.
In regarding to yoga, also yoga means
unity. So what we think about yoga
now, we think about movement, but it's
always accompanied by reaching
state of concentration through
meditation. So you
cannot have yoga without meditation,
otherwise you'll be stretching or
pilates. But second
topic is that can
it happen when you don't have prediction
of movement? Right? No, I meant
like because in yoga at least I don't
really do yoga, right? But I can imagine
that when people reach those states
doing yoga, then they kind of do it
almost like in a trance type of way.
They're always doing the same movement
over and over and over again so that
they don't have to attend to those
movements. But it's just like an
automatic process. I was wondering if
that also can I jump in?
Actually, this is precisely the
opposite. What Valerie was saying is so
Valerie was saying this is precisely the
opposite. You want to reach through yoga
just like the opposite of automatic. So
basically when you do this movements,
you need to be united with yourself
doing it. So you really need to I'm
doing yoga so the past ten years and
precisely this is like they're trying to
tell us don't do it on automatic.
Because it's like when you have your
thinking happening there and your body
is doing some stuff there, right. You
need to basically be presence in every
single type of moon. So you have like
fully, fully presence if you do it
automatically, that's more like
gymnastic or something. But it's
interesting. So your point is really
interesting because then would be really
nice to have a control condition where
we have people doing like movement,
meditation and yoga and then contrast
with the phenomena of some other sense
retenuation and whether they have what
type of embodiment and disembodiment and
gentivity experiences they have.
Okay, I don't know exactly what I was
trying to get it. But I think it was
also more related to because you said
that when meditating you have to sort of
let yourself letting go. Letting go,
exactly. And the idea is that everything
has to be perfectly sort of predictable,
right? That's the idea behind it. So
then I'm thinking so within yoga,
don't you have to do the exact same
movements in order for it to be
predictable, in order for you to let go
and not overatten to the environment?
Does that make sense?
I thought when we both and Simon were
speaking I think on one side you,
Simon, maybe you're referring to the
implicit procedural knowledge that you
can acquire through yoga and you, Ana,
are talking about doing things without
being aware, which is also automatic and
left. And you both are right, I think in
this because on one Anna, you would
say like if you do yoga, you learn how
to do yoga, right? So you learn how
to move yourself
in this way so that when you do a
certain position that you have to
arrange your body and for arrange your
dirty, you always have to keep
monitoring yourself. So there is a
continuous going back to your body,
keeping track of your body and continue
to monitor yourself. But in this way
because you have learned to do this
going back and being aware on yourself.
And this comes also when you do your
movement, you have learned that certain
posture are made in a certain way so
that it becomes more or less predictable
actually what you're going to do.
Right. But it doesn't mean that you
don't have to be awareness and actually
there is a trick ribbon here because
you're very attentive with what's going
on but at the same time the more you're
attentive, the more somatosensory
attenuation may happen. And actually
it's what we are trying to argue in our
active inference model. The more
predictable it gets, the more it gets
attenuated, but doesn't mean that you're
not aware.
Thank you for this input because it
helps us elaborate this. I think it's
super interesting because it's like when
you look at people that climb or surf or
whatever, any type of sports, right? In
the beginning, in order to learn the
skill, you have to put a lot of
attention to the individual movements
but then later on, in order to actually
be good at it, you have to take the
attention away. And then in those
moments is when the people report that
they're actually feeling sort of
selfless states and these flow is when
the movements are internalized, so to
speak. I think that's super interesting.
Can I just shoot the other two questions
I had? They're sort of different or
should we go to Julia first? Maybe it's
Julia.
Hi, sorry. Yeah, sorry for the lighting
and sorry because I'm in the lab, so
it's probably not the best position.
Thank you. Varia it was very interesting
and I'm really looking forward to look
at the results you have in your study.
Especially since as Anna mentioned, we
had something interesting with the
international binding and
depersonalization and yeah, kind of
happy about that. I'm really sorry
because I listened kind of doing
something else. Unfortunately in the lab
I was busy while you were talking. But I
kind of like this idea. Yeah. Does the
self is attenuated or not or increasing
and kind of goes back to just Simon.
The last comment from Simon about
expertise. I think in
term of motor interaction there is some
literal jobability expert. I was trying
to Google that, but I attended a
workshop last year, and I think it was
about once you're an expert.
At the beginning, you have this kind of
flexible you have a better understanding
consciousness, and then at the end, you
kind of learn to let it go, to ride the
flow of the motion, kind of.
And I think it's probably the same. I
don't know about attention in meditation
is that you have to maybe more like not
focus attentional state but more
like open.
Sorry, I forgot the name of the
meditation type of meditation. But open
meditation, open monitoring. Yeah,
exactly. I don't know. So it would be
interesting and I suggested to see what
type of meditation maybe changed the
sense of the self. Maybe at the
beginning it's more acute because you
really scrutinize your sensation.
I don't know. This is something that you
plan to do, right?
Should I go or do you want to go on the
the first question was there
is a body of evidence that actually say
that in expert meditators tension start
decreasing. But there is also
because you allocate less and less
attention. But I would be careful with
that with this because they
say there is decreased
activity in anterior singleet cortex.
So they make inference about it as
meditators as well. And having
to know other people that are more
experienced than me, they would never
say we lose our attention to that
because our experience is so rich of
sensory signals and related thought
process that you cannot afford to not be
attentive. However, we can bring into
the plate different kinds of attention.
As you said, there is focused attention
or there's an attention that requires
more explicit thought about it.
So more explicit kind of way to
focus on things and there is more like a
bare attention. So when you focus on the
whole experience and you let it go with
a non judgmental attitude and more open
attitude and it's actually these
attitudes, they're very stressed in
meditation techniques, that's why
they're a bit underlooked. And in
research I feel because it's a lot about
how we use attention but not the
attention but not how we use intention.
So the
attitude of the meditator has to be very
open and very non judgmental and these
reduce the nonreactive senses for
example and reduce the ability to
self regulate your experience.
Partially answered. Yeah,
I kind of like the idea that you link
that with attention and just I think
maybe it would be interesting to look at
different type of attention because
maybe there is a difference between I
don't know, different type of meditation
may develop different type of maybe the
open meditation is more
prone. I don't know because you
mentioned the insula cortex and to me
it's more associated with certain type
of attention. Like more like maybe more
prone for feedback or negativity
or these kind of error monitoring
process. So it's not like your
attention, you lose your attention.
It's just it's more like in the
background and then when there is a
mistake or something it kind of pops up
more quickly. I don't know. And you may
have more frontal or
sustain attention. I don't know. I mean
I'm not a specialist of attention at
all. So please take that with a grain of
salt. Yeah. I was wondering if this is
something, I don't know obviously
because you're not planning to do any
EEG or neurophysiological
measurement. Right. So this is maybe
like a follow up study that would be
interesting. Not yet,
but in the pipeline. Yeah. Okay.
What we really want with Valeria is
and other collaborators is to basically
push against this idea that you can have
selfless experiences. I know it's
controversial and many people talk about
oh, selfless experience blah.
So basically we want to say radically
speaking okay, so that works if you bite
the bullet and you're mind body dualist
and somehow consider that actually the
body kind of like disappears in the
process. But if you're not mind body
dualist then you need to basically put
the body into equation and realize that
actually what allows the mind to
disappear is the fact into the pureness
of the experience is the fact that the
impure body is kind of like put in
a stable condition in such a way that
basically you can afford to leave it in
the background and to have this type of
experience arising. But without that in
place you can't really afford to
go through this selfless experiences.
And this is why we want to be
provocative in the titles that well
actually maybe the experience of
selfless experiences actually comes
necessarily as two sign of the same coin
of this experience of having an
unlimited body that actually expands
through the world. But the body is
there. I mean the thing, the entity that
has the experience of no experience
is that a body that kind of
is self regulated in a certain way
like the homeostasis is put at like a
set point. And when you're using this
metaphor of think of a
cyclone, right, moving cyclone so you
have the steel eye of the cyclone in the
middle doesn't mean that actually it's
not there. It's just like it's around
everything. And because we are self
organizing biological systems.
This animal, this thing needs to keep
track of this internal bodily states.
And a successful system does this
all the time. All the time, literally
from second one, when we basically get
from one cell to the self. So this is
some sort of fascinating self
organization that is happening on the
cellular level already and it needs to
be. And death is basically this is what
is happening. It's like disintegration
of this self organization.
But clearly that's not what is happening
on meditation, right? Because hopefully
you don't die when you meditate. In that
sense. There is disintegration of a
certain way to experience yourself in
relation to the body in the world, but
clearly there's something that stays
there and needs to stay there for you to
have those experiences. So that's a bit
of controversial, radical claim that we
like to defend. And yeah, we already had
this discussion with several people.
For instance, like Valerie and I, we
went to Enlightenment, this workshop on
phrenology neurocompetition. We met
there with people like Thomas Betziger
and everything and obviously they have a
different opinion. So we kind of, like,
have a lively discussion about why we
think it's like, what does it mean
to actually lose yourself and what is
the self and what is a pure experience
and why we basically need whether we're
like it or not, the connection with the
impure body to make sure that you can
have, at a certain point, a pure
experience. But then again, this is
something that just speculation at the
theory level. And this is why I have
this brilliant team here that we can do
some studies and actually measure stuff,
put the finger on it, put the number and
see what we get.
These are awesome points and there's so
many ways it could go. I'll read a
question from the live chat. So G
Pagnani wrote, the notion of
increased Somatosensory transparency in
experienced meditators associated with
increased liveliness of the experience
is intriguing. Can you say something
about which levels in the hierarchical
structure of the internal model are more
likely to be affected by the meditative
attentional task in terms of precision
deployment? Do you think the attenuation
of Somatosensory prediction error
concerns more intermediate levels in a
way increase meta awareness rather than
sheer sensory attention?
I can take this one. So I
can give a fuzz go and then you can go.
No, I just wanted to ask rather than
ensuring.
Rather than sheer sensory attention.
Yeah, you can go on now, please.
Yeah, so this is something I'm
trying to develop this idea right now
with a PhD student of
mine,
Libetise, basically. And this is why
it's connected with the question that
you ask, you'll see, is that your
platform is active inference, right?
And so people kind of know lately
kind of realize, wait a minute,
actually we are active and we need to
explain action in the world and
everything kind of like comes late,
right? But if you look going back to the
animal, basically the action and the
movement is there from the very
beginning. So this means that this is
why it's so important to basically
relate the self organization,
self awareness, self perception
necessarily related with movement. So
movement an action is not something that
you add on the top of this, right? Like
some of intention. So you can have an
intention, but basically the first
movements are kind of like automatic and
need to be there, right? And basically
our body moves all the time because we
breathe all the time and our heart beats
all the time. So this means that for me,
this type of attenuation is happening at
the sensory level because that's the
basic one. So can you have sensory stuff
without metacognitive stuff? Yes. Can
you have metacognitive stuff without
sensory stuff? No. So it's like what is
basic that's the first things needs to
be attenuated
and then there has to be a balance
between metacognitive and sensory
attenuation because this is precisely
what I think it is happening in
Depersonalization because if you focus
too much, right? So you lose the balance
between then it's
kind of like this type of you cannot
afford to self forget yourself. And then
it's kind of like the self stands in the
way and that gets you even more
disconnected, so to speak. So this is
why I think it's important to contrast
different type of meditative experiences
and meditative practices to see which
one of them actually has more focus on
what you do with metacognitive,
metawareness awareness of awareness and
which one are actually involving more
like sensory movement, for instance,
let's say. Yeah, so that's something
that needs to be empirically tested.
But I would speculate and then obviously
we can put it at test, either by doing a
simulation or actually collecting data
to see how that plays into
this distinction.
I think Simon wants to say something,
but I'm not the moderator. So Daniel,
you decide. Yeah. Valeria first.
Thank you, Anna.
I don't have so much more to say because
I agree with her. But I thought
when Daniel you were reading the
question for me the answer was
more or less clear in the sense that as
I say, the Somatosens continuation
happens the very low level predictions.
So in a very pre
reflective self consciousness, so that
the person was asking in
the meditation techniques, when you put
the attention on, for example, your
bodily signals there, you have a top
down modulation of this, of precision
wasting, but the top down modulation is
on low level predictions. So you're not
putting top down on what you think about
your body is you're actually doing the
opposite. You're trying to forget about
your previous expectations about
the body because you're trying to have
this non judgmental awareness about
what's going on in your experience. And
then with this,
let's say, less biased way
to attend your body. You start piercing
and perceiving bodily
sensations in your body or other
kind of experiences. So I would say this
increasing precision on somatosensory
signals happens at the low level of the
Yerarchy that then attenuates the
sensory consequences of the
posterior. And the meta
awareness comes when you learn,
I think, when you start having increased
body awareness. So you make more
experience. I think then you start
developing meta awareness about how your
body is actually about higher
representation of the body of your body.
But in the moment when this happens, I
think it really happens at the low
level, subpersonal beliefs. And then
later on, on the longer time scales,
then it starts becoming more
abstract and ingrained at
the personal level of your beliefs.
That's how I say it. But of course, if
Simon has something to do with it, it's
really I. Didn'T I didn't want to
comment. I just selfishly raised my hand
to. Ask another question or Daniel,
I don't know if you have an opinion on
that. I'm happy to hear it as well.
Well, certainly resonated
with this comparative approach to
studying the diversity of methods
and protocols we already have for mind
and body and attention, broadening the
scope and just kind of putting darts in
the space of what practices do people
engage their mind and body in?
And then, how can that territory be
explored with also a variety of
theoretical models? And how does that
relationship connect to the kinds of
empirical work that we might do in a
brain scanner or with other kinds of
measuring? And I think one thing
I want to explore more
is in a hierarchical nested cognitive
model, which we often speak of ourselves
and other types of sophisticated
entities as where's our awareness?
Where's awareness in that picture?
And also to Simone's question about when
we're moving, but we're expecting
what we're moving, then how does the
exteriorceptive flow? Like the visual
field? You might be very familiar with
walking, and so you might be able to
proprioceptively kind of zero out on
your walking, but there's this
exteriorceptive flow of novelty
in the world. So I think that how and
then connect it back to the comparative
and staring at a candle or a blank
screen or darkness and all these
different methods.
There's a lot that these questions bring
up. Yeah. Thank you, Daniel. So I have
something to add to that because I think
it's super know,
my background is like, embodied
cognition and activists and everything.
And for me, it's really not at all
surprising the fact that many of these
techniques have been developed by people
that kind of, like, lived in closed
communities. Right. So it's like you
have a space where people can meditate
walking. I don't know. And then they
have this ritual. They wake up at this
time and they do this thing. So you put
yourself in yeah, it's a ritual. Right.
Like all the rituals. So this means,
as I said, it's like high
predictability. Right. And then
that's something super important. And
even in the Wokie meditation, you need
to follow a certain path.
Yes. So that's super interesting.
Well, in the last five
or ten minutes, I would love to hear
from each of you, like, what are your
directions heading forward and what's
exciting to you and where would you like
to take this? Maybe Simone
and Julia first, and then we'll kind of
make our way back to the.
Not myself, not working on the project.
Right. But what I was really interested
in sort of extending this is trying to
understand because
the way those deep meditative states are
reported sometimes and the way people
with depersonalization disorder report
their experience is very similar. They
almost use, like, the same words right.
And to describe how they feel. And I
wonder why one is experienced positively
and one is experienced so negatively,
as in it being a disorder and in
completely disrupting someone's life.
So that was like this comparison I think
I'll be very curious about.
Awesome. Julia, if you want to add
anything.
Well, it's very interesting.
Again, I'm not so involved in this
study, so it's a bit hard, but I'm
really interested in all the self is
affected by our interaction with the
world, external world, and I'm
completely already spoiled with the
result we have with the international
binding. So it's very if
the self is attenuated or if it's
disappeared, kind of I think that's the
key question we want to answer. And
yeah, I would be very curious to mean
what Valeria found in data to
see if we can have a common narrative
about what's happening. Also with the
personalization. Yeah. It's very
interesting to see how moving of body,
attention to the body can really change
the self, kind of or the way we process
self information. Yeah. So very
interesting.
Cool. Anna.
Yes. So it's like lots of work
to do ahead, but that's exciting,
right? Yeah. So, very short
term, it's like we need to write up this
result that we just got. So yeah. In
relation to the body. So basically,
we're going to have some numbers to
show. So that's super nice. And then the
next steps would be to create
or develop computational model around
this, basically contrast
the real world data with, you know,
simulation data and then have
a multilayered type of approach with
different methods, from physiological to
behavioral to phenomenological to
computational, potentially also neural.
So that's something would be nice to do
in the next steps.
And apart from that, I think that's all
for now, and I'll leave
the floor to Valeria.
Well, again, thank you, Dan and
everybody. Yeah. I also want to
thank you a lot for this platform, this
invitation. It was really nice. Really
nice person and really nice
conversation. I'm working with Anne
Andy's project, so she already said,
what's the next direction? What. I can
add in this I think would be on
the theoretical side also start engaging
with more closely
to bodily reactions to meditation
because the body boundaries dissolution
is just one part of it. It's like one
part of the phenomenology but it's not
the only thing that happens during
meditation. There is a lot of potential
that can be discovered on this because
the body boundary solution again, it's
really study a lot, but it's a
phenomenon and there is so many other
things that happens in our body while we
meditate and I speak for first person
experience, but in the community it's
really like already said, other kinds of
also more healing traditions like
breath work, for example. There there is
a lot of potential where people already
work on that. But there is no bridge
with the academic communities. So people
work pragmatically with this intuitive
knowledge about what happens in the body
during these altered states of
consciousness but still we need to
bridge it with trying to make sense from
a phonological and scientific point of
view and experimental point of view as
well. So I think I see myself in trying
to step in this toward and bring insight
from one world to the other and hoping
to help myself and the other people
around me.
Awesome. Well, best of luck with the
work. That sounds really exciting. Love
the idea of the two way street with
different bodily and cognitive practices
and collaboration and conversation that
can bring in all these different
expertises that maybe don't have an fMRI
study already, whatever that's worth.
Thank you though, always. Any of you are
welcome back and really appreciate that
you all came out. Thank you.
Daniel, thank you. See you soon.